okay everybody we have more Avengers for
leaks this is going to be more frequent
the closer we get to the trailer release
and the closer we get to the movie
coming out as well
as I said in one of my previous videos
there are so many people involved in
making movies which makes it really hard
to keep everything a secret especially
toys which is what I think this picture
is about I'm still giving away some
copies of infinity war and ant-man and
the wasp on blu-ray as well as some
special edition posters all you have to
do to enter the giveaway is subscribe to
my channel like the video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so this picture looks
like it was put on a monitor in a
boardroom and one of the employees
snapped a picture of it again I think
this is probably for a toy line but
let's talk about what we can see so
starting with the top right we can see
Thor and rocket and they're wearing the
same suits that they were wearing in the
other leaked photo that we got not too
long ago
Thor has Stormbreaker next to him and
rocket has his gun I think that the
objects to their right are helmets I
originally thought that they could be
Infinity stones but since every single
person on this photo has one I'm going
with their helmets and if you take a
look just under them you can clearly see
Captain America he has his shield but he
also is wearing one of the same suits
that Thor and raka is wearing I believe
that these suits are for traveling
inside of the quantum realm we know that
the quantum realm is going to play a
huge part in Avengers 4 and we know that
you have to wear a suit to handle the
environment of the quantum realm that is
unless you're Captain Marvel who is to
the right of Captain America there
Captain Marvel is supposed to be linked
to the quantum realm as it is plus she's
supposed to be one of the strongest
characters to be introduced into the MCU
this could possibly explain why she's
not wearing a suit in this photo also
her suit is probably made by the Kree
and who knows what kind of technology
they have then we have iron man who's
just wearing his normal suit but this
makes sense because if Hank Pym suits
can survive inside of the quantum realm
I'm sure Tony Stark suits can as well
but if they couldn't I'm sure he would
just design himself a new Iron Man suit
that could survive in the quantum realm
but keep the same look of course so then
we have this new
character to the right of Iron Man if
you look closely you can tell that it's
sort of a feminine shape and it's
definitely an Iron Man suit so this is
rescue rescue is the Iron Man armor that
Pepper Potts wears in the comics the
armor was originally called the mark
16:16 but eventually became known as the
rescue armor do to rescue being the
alias Pepper Potts adapted while wearing
the armor so this is a huge deal Pepper
Potts is going to be suiting up in the
rescue armor in Avengers 4 this makes
sense we've seen her back on set for
reshoots I think we all just assumed
that they were maybe some sort of love
scene with Tony Stark
but seems like she's putting on some
armor in Avengers 4 so then we go to the
bottom left and we have three characters
here that are kind of hard to make out
the middle one is obviously Thanos he
has his double bladed sword and he has
his armor on the person to his right
though it's kind of hard to make out
looks like the Hulk I'm gonna go ahead
and say it's the Hulk although I can't
100% make it out he is about the same
size as Thanos to the left of them he
does seem to be wearing some sort of
suit so maybe he'll be going inside of
the quantum realm as well but we also
know that he's most likely going to
become Professor Hulk in Avengers 4 so
maybe this has something to do with that
as far as everybody else it's really
hard to make it out the photo is just
too blurry I do think I see Ronan at the
top here I think these shapes to the
left of them could possibly be his
swords that he wields as Ronan but as
far as the rest of them I can't really
make them out it's too hard to tell but
if you have any idea and if you think
you know who they are
let me know also let me know what you
think about these new suits and about
them introducing rescue and Avengers 4
leave your thoughts in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway for your chance to
win a copy of infinity war ant-man and
the wasp and some special edition
posters and so you can stay up to date
on everything related to Avengers 4 as
always thank you all so much for
watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]